good morning everyone my name is Juan
Vasquez I am going to be your presenter
trainer for this next hour and a half or
we're gonna get into some web scraping
I'll be telling you a little bit about
myself and most definitely what the next
nighti or so minutes look like but I
just want to thank you all for being
here for coming to my session for you
know choosing to invest in and your
learning and being here on a Tuesday
general show of hands who's feeling good
about the conference so far who has
learned a good amount of things good
exposure excellent that's good to hear
and so we're gonna be talking about web
scraping using two two strategies we're
gonna be looking at how to scrape with
beautifulsoup and also how to scrape
Yelp listings using their Yelp API a
little bit about me before we get too
deep into the data part of things again
Juan Vasquez by day I am the data
programs manager at the city's office of
Finance I am part of one of 43
departments that make up our local city
infrastructure as far as local
government goes and we're really our
city's primary revenue collector and
generators so every year we collect
about 4.5 billion dollars that then feed
into our general fund that impacts
things like Public Safety a lot of the
fires and LA of the efforts that you
know we really desperately need and then
just the general functions of the city
those roughly four point five billion
dollars come in the form of city
business tax permits and then collection
so for example if someone gets in in a
car accident and maybe they were they
had a DUI they impact some public
property that goes to the city attorney
and then eventually it has to be
collected on that's also something my
department handles so it's a lot of
business functions we have about 400
employees 12 divisions so it's a big
organization it's one of the larger
departments the city has I am there
largely to help bring a data lens and a
data perspective to different types of
business problems so I typically cycle
through projects I help different
business units
implement data practices and data
management standards if they don't have
any if they already have some sort of
data management infrastructure I helped
make it better I hate standardized
automate optimize processes try to cut
down reporting time tell stories through
our data using dashboards and
interactive maps that's a lot of what I
do day to day I also teach data
analytics weekends and nights a General
Assembly typically a six week online
course on advanced excel sequel and
tableau and I also do freelance kind of
data services my wife and I recently got
married this year we bought a home in
Boyle Heights thank you
we're big la FC fans for anyone that's a
dis ocker here in the room and so that's
a little bit about me also just kind of
a moment of empathy and being real with
you all this is my first time speaking
and teaching on Python so this year I
took it upon myself to learn the
language I was done with tools
I'm a former advertiser so that's what I
went to school for that's what I did at
the beginning of my career and over
these last ten years as a working
professional I've realized the power and
importance of programming languages and
so I can do a lot of things with tools
but the reality is there's a very real
roof as far as how high my career can go
and my salary can go and my professional
opportunities can go without a command
of a programming language Python was my
language of choice and so what you're
gonna see here is really the result of
the last 11 months or so of work meaning
my general level of comfort so I'm not a
subject-matter expert I'm a strategic
communicator who has turned into a data
analyst I'm exploring data science and
really loved it and want to be better at
it but I am in what you're gonna see
here is in no way perfect definitely a
lot of room to improve and optimize my
code and all of that so just in case
anyone here is from maybe a
non-traditional career background just
know I empathize and also a little bit
of expectation setting I just want to be
very real with you all as far as where
I'm at in my data journey okay we're
gonna do two tutorials and then we
should have some room for Q&A at the end
perhaps 10-15 minutes and so this is
what we're gonna also I
I tweet and Instagram a good bit about
these things so anyone trying to use
social media to consume more of this
content there is my handle and also my
website so this is what we're getting
into for the next you know hour and a
half or so we're just gonna quickly talk
about why scrape data why is that
helpful how can it support business
functions and operations then we're
gonna do a brief overview of what the
tutorials will be so broad strokes we're
gonna think about how these concepts fit
together so that you go from information
on a website
to manageable useful data and some sort
of vehicle that you can you know bring
into your work or or do analysis on then
after that overview we're gonna do a bit
of strategy around yellow pages which
will be our first use case and then
we'll go scrape some yellow pages and
then we'll reset we'll do a little bit
of strategy around Yelp and then we'll
go scrape some Yelp data and then at the
end we'll have some Q&A and you know
what kind of see how this goes so
kicking things off why why scrape in the
first place
scraping is the practice of of accessing
data that lives in a third party site
for example and and bringing it to an
environment that you yourself can use
perhaps a notebook like we'll be using
today CSV files Excel files anything
that that gives you some sort of command
or ownership over that data and so
that's how I view web scraping there are
two really good reasons why web scraping
can be useful the first is that you can
use it to drive traffic and awareness
about the topics you care about so I'll
quickly share one personal example when
I started getting into data the first
thing I ever scraped was 2018 World Cup
data and built this tableau dashboard
that you see up here I'll give it a
second to load and so you can use web
scraping external data sources to drive
awareness bring attention web traffic
have conversations build narratives
build a portfolio piece perhaps and so
this this was something that was
interactive and kind of tracked team
performance as the the
went on landing on the eventual winner
friends at the bottom we have goals and
so this was all scraped from ESPN using
Google sheets so some of the import
functions which we're not gonna get into
today but this is where my my kind of
journey scraping data started and it's
definitely been helpful having a
portfolio piece so so an example of how
you can scrape data to drive attention
to a particular website newsletter
content social media content you know if
there's if you work for a non-profit a
foundation a for-profit business and you
want to drive dialogue and educational
efforts you want to inform users about a
topic you can scrape data and build some
sort of web product that then you can
promote to and promote against and again
inform and educate you can also use
scrape data as an intelligence tool this
is largely what we use scrape data for
at the office of Finance basically get
smarter about what is happening in and
around you and see how it can inform
your business functions and operations
so we've been scraping Yellow Pages data
and Yelp data to get a sense of what the
business landscape looks like in Los
Angeles you know we have a perspective
of that based on our own data collection
and people registering with us but if we
analyze the up data and and yellow pages
data which is what we're doing now then
we can really think about what what
might be we missing and where might be
some good areas to target to Center
humans we're walking the fine line
between soliciting against this data and
so that there's some legalities as to
what you can and can't do but you can
really also enrich your existing data
and and again grow intelligence and make
better more informed decisions about
your resource allocation and things like
that also I know many startups and
smaller businesses don't have a lot of
data available and so if you're trying
to learn more about human behavior and
what your potential customers were there
ad and what they're doing you can use
scrape data and open data to inform kind
of your market research and things like
that so a little bit on why scraping is
important right now at Finance we are
bringing in this scrape the yellow pages
and Yelp data into scorecards that we
can use with other external data sources
to
is seen how many listings might a
business appear and use that to qualify
our leads any any general thoughts any
questions on what scraping might be or
any point of clarification there just
want to create some space in case anyone
has anything so real quick overview of
what we'll be working on and what code
will be writing out and and in fact how
we will be scraping so we're gonna use
three primary tools or libraries or
modules we're gonna use the request
library in both of our use cases and
we're gonna use beautifulsoup to scrape
yellow pages data and then we will use
the Yelp fusion API to scrape Yelp
listings and so a request helps us
handle web calls and an actual web
requests that grab some sort of HTTP
information and package it up in a way
that you can use with other libraries
and then beautifulsoup is a great
library to help you handle actual HTML
structure and it in read HTML tags and
and you don't do analysis or in this
case scrape data from there now Yelp is
very much aware that people want their
data and they want to use their data so
they've created their Fusion API with
which lets you search their listings and
extract at a rate of maximum 50 listings
per call and they have definitely
thresholds and so we actually need
everyone to create a Yelp developer
account so show of hands here who has a
Yelp developer account who plans to
follow along okay show of hands here who
doesn't have a Yelp developer account
and plans to follow along okay then
let's let's take it doesn't take very
long just take out like three minutes or
so to create a Yelp developer account
and to do that you'll just need to
Google Yelp developer and then your
Google results you'll have Yelp Fusion
there something like this we'll be using
the business Search API click into your
fusion and get to a place where you can
get started
so again Google Yelp developer then
select fusion and then click get started
you'll be prompted to create an account
and then we'll need to create an
application so go ahead and set up those
accounts for everyone who already has an
account show of hands here if you have
an account do you also have already an
app set up so you have a key to work
with no ok so if you don't have if
you've already created your Yelp
developer account you'll want to click
manage app and from here you'll need to
create one so that you in fact get this
type of API client ID and API key
alright we're gonna be starting with the
Yellow Pages so if you still need to set
up a last few things we'll create space
for this as we transition from Yellow
Pages to Yelp a little bit on how you
can think about this web scraping use
case and you know as you all probably
know when it comes to programming and
working with languages there are many
ways to get to the same destination and
so this is my approach to this again
there are ways to make it more optimal
and you can definitely think of other
ways to scrape data broad strokes what
we're gonna be doing is is prepping our
notebook setting up our code setting up
our libraries then we're gonna be
targeting specific pieces of data either
by targeting HTML tags or by targeting
objects in the JSON response that the
Yelp API will generate for us so we'll
prepper are kind of working
infrastructure our layout of data will
target the data we want then whatever we
scrape we're gonna append to existing
lists and then we're gonna use those
lists to structure a data frame so this
is the process we're gonna be taking our
data we're gonna prep our tools the
tools we need we're gonna target the
data we want we're gonna append that
data to empty lists and then we're gonna
structure it in a data frame and then we
can get the data frame out or do further
analysis
some more specific tools that we will
need to work with f strings for loops
lists and then the eventual data frame F
strings for loops lists and data frames
this will largely be echoed along so I
am cheating and I have my solutions open
in a tab so I gets if I get stuck I will
be peaking but these are some of the
extra kind of ingredients we'll need to
work with along you know as we kind of
follow these broad steps alright now
that we have a broad understanding of
what we'll be doing will be prepping
targeting appending and then structuring
and then using a few additional
structures we're gonna be using a
notebook so originally I had plans to
use Jupiter notebooks if you want to use
that go for it but I don't know if you
all use Google colab notebooks it's
basically a Google Drive alternative to
a notebook you can access it through
this website right here bit ly /yp
underscore scrape go ahead and head
there I tested it this morning it should
all be working fine if you don't if you
you must have at the very least a gmail
account if you don't you can download
the notebook and perhaps open it up in
anaconda but ideally if you have a gmail
account just make a copy of it it will
view this in a second make a copy of it
and and we'll work through it together
bit ly /yp underscore scrape it should
look like this just an empty notebook
with a handful of headers that will
provide us direction we're gonna use
this to scrape our Yellow Pages data and
in a minute we're gonna kind of lay out
a strategy on how we're gonna be
targeting the different HTML objects
within the Yellow Pages website it's
right here bit bi t dot ly /yp
underscore scrape
bit dot ly Forge slash
for /yp underscore scrape thumbs up if
you got it open does anyone need any any
assistance or help okay and it should be
something like this if you go to file
you can save a copy in your drive and
then go to it you won't be able to edit
this based on our permission settings so
you need to make a copy of it that you
can you can use this is just like a
Google Doc is just like Google slides
any other Google product just shareable
collaborative notebooks there are
definitely some limitations and in how
it reads and interprets code but this
has been a pretty sweet product to work
with so go ahead and make save a copy
open it up in your drive and then we're
gonna head to the Yellow Pages and do
some strategy so here we have the Yellow
Pages the reason I use beautifulsoup to
scrape the Yellow Pages is because their
data lives right within the HTML
structure of the page and so it just
made itself very scrape Abul using the
beautifulsoup library so we're going to
inspect the HTML of this page we're
going to identify the specific tags we
want and we're gonna think through how
to actually target them with our code
okay so here we have a listing of
businesses if you just go to
yellowpages.com
and search for example the legal section
you get a long list of businesses in in
my exploring of the Yellow Pages it
seemed like they bundled together all of
their data into broadly eight categories
which you can see in the Browse button
section here so typically the all of
their businesses regardless of how
granular a description they end up
having or how specialized they are they
typically seem to be bucketed into these
broad categories that you see here and
so if we just start exploring the data
that's available to us you will see that
there are some business some ads running
at the top
it's gone oh sorry I clicked into an end
that's what happened so you'll see that
a listing for any section usually starts
with an ad at the top which we're going
to exclude from our scrape when I first
started scraping this page I included
the ads and I realized that the way the
information is structured within an ad
varies ad to ad and is different from
the organic listings and so it will mess
with our eventual structure so we're now
going to scrape any ads instead we're
only gonna scrape the actual organic
listings that appear here so if you look
at any given business here we see that
we have a name
we'll want that we have a description
here we have a phone number right here
310 we have an address and so we're
gonna scrape all of those objects out of
HTML as tags and add the text portion of
that to a list and so let's explore now
the HTML let's see how to figure out how
to get all the phone numbers and the
names and all that stuff so if you're on
a Mac it was our question
we can the question was are we planning
on scraping the ratings yeah I wasn't
planning on it but we can see how the
data lives and and see we can scrape it
so again we have broad strokes we have a
listing for a business here now if
you're in a Mac with no buttons do a
two-finger click into your mouse if you
have buttons it should be your right
mouse button you want to open up this
dialog box right here this little dialog
box again to finger click or right click
and this will give you the opportunity
to inspect the HTML code behind the
front-facing website and so that's what
we want go ahead and open up the dialog
box and then click inspect now on the
right side we see basically the anatomy
of the website all of its bones and
muscles and structure and now we just
need to figure out what are the actual
tag names that represent the actual
pieces of data within the listing and
then we'll feed that into our eventual
for loop and just iterate through page
and listing grabbing all of that and
appending it to separate lists and then
bringing it all together in in one data
frame let's use our friend the arrow in
the top left corner of your kind of HTML
document for anyone that that hasn't I
expect most people have played around
with the inspect in some capacity but if
you haven't that arrow will identify the
object on the screen you're clicking
into it will identify it within the HTML
structure so let's quickly use our
friend the arrow to identify the tag
names that we'll want to scrape and now
it's a game of trying to get as granular
as you can
so what we find is that the business
name is hidden or not hidden it lives
within our h2 container with a class of
n so we're gonna use that h2 header with
the class name n to target all of the
business names and so this is the type
of exploration we have to do to identify
all of our relevant data pieces and so
go ahead and and let's find one more and
then I'll just give you all a list of
all of the tag names we'll be using so
we use more of our time writing code and
not exploring HTML so we have the
business name at h2 class name n we also
want the description beneath it let's
see if we can zero in on that that is a
div called categories or with a class
name of categories and so it's gonna be
a second one all right so that's an
example of two you could do this game
for every piece of a business listing
but if you want to go ahead and write
down on a piece of paper on a sticky
note on your computer I'm gonna give you
the I think it's five different tags
we're gonna pull every one of them would
be the same workflow so we're going to
we're gonna scrape the h2 tag with class
n which we already looked at we're going
to scrape a div with class of phone
phone primary again the name is gonna be
an h2 n class the phone number is going
to be a div with class name phone phone
primary the address is going to be a div
with class name Street - address
we have two more the city and zip code
which are not included in the div that I
just mentioned that's gonna be a div
with a class name of locality and then
the last one is this kind of bucket of
more granular descriptions those are
categories and so that's gonna be a div
called categories all right so we'll
start structuring your code around these
ki HTML tags h2 div div div div now
there's one more thing we have to take
into account you didn't know this up
until now our organic listings live
within one large div that is called info
actually let me rephrase that each of
our organic business listings lives
within a div that is called info and so
we're gonna be first collecting all of
the listing divs and then looping
through those grabbing all the pieces
this is the way we're gonna exclude our
paid ads okay so that's a little bit of
the strategy we're going to do we've
identified the tags that we want to
target now we'll follow what we laid out
kind of as our strategy of prepping our
our notebook targeting our HTML
appending it and then structuring it all
together using mostly for loops and
empty lists so go ahead and head over to
the notebook that I shared with you all
and make sure you're on the working copy
you're your own working copy all right
are we all on a working thumbs up if
you're on a working copy of your
notebook okay
does anyone need a minute getting to
their notebook all right so we need to
first prep our notebook we need to
import the three main libraries will be
using so again we're using requests
beautifulsoup
and pandas so let's import requests as
our import the way we take or we import
beautifulsoup
is we need to import BS 4 & 4 beautiful
so if I have that right
so import requests are from bs4 import
beautifulsoup and then import pandas as
usual as PD all right and I'm curious
show of hands who's using the collab
notebook who's using your own Jupiter
notebook cool okay alright so we have
our libraries imported we have the
building blocks for the tools we need
now we need to create a list of all of
the URLs that a scraper needs to hit to
then peel into and grab the HTML objects
so we first need a list of URLs to
iterate through and to target our HTML
objects Thank You Nick this is Nick
everybody just say hello to Nick for a
second he's my assistant helping here so
if you need some help
yeah Nick thank you come on in clutch
with the water alright so I got us
started with the URL that we need and so
the way we're going to create our list
of URLs is so if we look at the current
URL structure for legal
we need to dissect a little bit of how
this data lives you will see that the
URL is the same for every page the only
thing that changes is the number at the
end so everything stays the same for our
URL structure the only thing that
changes is the number at the end and so
the way we're going to create our list
of URLs is by using this base string and
then using an F string to attach a range
of 102 numbers basically covering the
entire category of legal and packaging
that up into one list that then we can
iterate over and so the way we're going
to do that is we already have our first
object up here we have a string of text
that is legal we now need to create our
range of 102 digits to effectively
attach at the end of all of our URLs so
you can just call this pages and this is
a range with a hundred and two numbers
now we also need an empty list to
eventually attach all of our specific
more granular URLs so let's go ahead and
create an empty business list
and now let's create our first four loop
that grabs this long URL the string of
text and iterates over it attaching and
a specific page number at the end of it
and we're gonna use an F string to do
this if you want to take it another
route feel free to go for it but just
feel free to follow along as well so for
page in pages no sorry for page yeah in
pages want to iterate over that last
number we want to create a legal URL
that using an F string brings together
the long string of text available up in
our legal object and adds to it whatever
number it is currently looping at so
here's a little bit of that code we have
we're entering of our pages we're
creating a legal URL that is the result
of grabbing our bass string of text here
and attaching each of the numbers
available in our range and then lastly
we have that empty business list that
we're going to append the actual legal
URL that we've created up above
let's try it out let's see if this works
I have I where I should up page there we
go
let me quickly check alright so I I have
let's take a look at what this looks
like
and so you should have a long list of
URLs basically 102 URLs that use our
bass string here and attaches a number
at the end I'll leave this up for a
second
thumbs up if you're with me do we have
any questions okay we'll get folks a
second to finish this piece
now the next thing we're going to want
to do is nest together two four loops
that iterate through a list of URLs and
then for each page we want to iterate
through the listings and grab the key
pieces of data we want oh but we also
need some empty lists to store those
pieces of data in and then eventually
stitched together into a data frame so
we'll do that I see some folks still
typing so I just want to give us a
second here all right I'm gonna reset my
kernel and just run it again since I
already have my list because if we run
this for loop again we're just gonna
append that same batch into the existing
list so I'm just gonna reset my kernel
then we'll run this again all right so
I'm importing my libraries and then here
we're creating alright so now that we
have our list of URLs that we want to
iterate over we need based on my
strategy we need empty lists to store
each of those HTML objects that then
we'll stitch together into a data frame
and so let's initialize five different
lists that are empty lists that coincide
with the the listing data we want and so
we know we're gonna have names let's do
this together create a named list that's
empty create a phone list that's empty
create an address list locality list
that's where our city and zip are gonna
live and a categories list all empty
so now we have empty containers that we
can store our data in as we loop through
our pages and our individual listings
now let's let's start our two four loops
that together the outer four loop is
going to iterate through the pages and
the inner for loop is going to target
the key tags that we outlined before
and so here we're gonna be iterating
really over the the business list so we
want for every page in our business
business list for every page in our
business list we want to use requests to
get that page
and then we're going to create an HTML
doc that turns that request into text
and then from that HTML document we're
going to create our soup and that's
where all of our HTML tags are going to
live in a way that we can specifically
target them so we have our soup object
will call beautiful soup and we'll pass
in that HTML dog that we created above
so this is the top part of really yeah
that's our outer loop initially here
we're iterating through each page that
we created in the business list we're
turning that call into text that text is
then passed into beautiful soup
now I mentioned that all of our organic
listings excluding our ads live in
containers that are called info and so
we're going to create one more soup that
has only our organic listings and so I
call these organic listings and here
we're gonna call our soup object above
and we're gonna find all the divs that
our class name info and that concludes
our outer loop so now we have the run
way to iterate through every page and
now we need to decide what we want to do
with each of those pages and so here
we'll initialize our inner loop and what
we want is for every item in our organic
listings now we want five if-else
statements where if we find our HTML tag
then we want appended to one of our
empty lists if we don't have an object
there then we want to just write not not
available or no name no address that's
gonna be this strategy for our inner
loop again targeting each of the HTML
tags that we outlined and appending it
to an empty list or noting is not
available
and so if item has our h2 tag give it a
with a class name of n we need to append
it to the name list above name the
append and what we're pending is exactly
we find here
otherwise sorry
Oh up here sorry oh I threw the end yes
there thank you thank you pre-owned here
to here there we go oh and up top yeah
yeah yeah thank you appreciate that okay
and so if we don't have that then we
just want to pend you know name alright
so that's the first instance of us
targeting our tag appending it to an
empty list or inserting you know some
version of not available and so now
we're we have four more tags that we
want to target let's do that same thing
I'll read them off will append it to
that one of them's the list that we
created above and then once that's done
we'll we'll stitch together our data
frame just gonna copy this here
right here oh yes I'm missing one here
thank you
so for the second if statement we're
gonna target our phone number and so
here I need a div that is here's the
phone phone primary
you know I believe its phone singular
but let's let's just check
oh you're right phones plural phone
primary good catch thank you
and I will do no phone
got an extra ticket
that's a good question he has why is it
important to have a placeholder the way
that I've structured this having four
step or five separate lists that
eventually gets stuck together and turn
into a data frame it's important that
our listings align and so we don't have
a placeholder if it's if there's nothing
there that spot will basically be
skipped and so it will throw off the
order of our individual attributes in
our data and so to keep them all aligned
I'm inserting that and so this is an
example where there's probably a better
more efficient way to scrape our data so
we don't have to insert something blank
you know I've explored exporting it the
entire pieces of data as tuples just
kind of working through something but
that's that's why does that answer your
question all right so we got our phones
let's now do this for our address
locality and categories so if I find a
div whose class name is locality then
append that locality oh we got to change
our list names sorry
locality
locality for the phones we don't want to
pen to the nameless we want to append to
the phone list
so here we're targeting our locality div
if we find it appended to the locality
list if we don't find it append no
locality to that list
and then one above we want to pen the
phone number to the phone list not the
name list as I originally had it lastly
if we find a div categories class name
appended to
the categories list
ecology address phone locality address
phone or missing I'm sorry I skipped
address
here we go so we should have one two
three four five if statements each
corresponding to an empty list that we
initialized up above street address we
have and phone street address locality
and categories yes categories no address
alright I'm gonna try running this let's
see yeah yes uh yes oh that's a good
point yeah we can yes right here
sorry
that's true
here we'll do this rock oh that would
have been good yeah yeah rock all right
let's try that
thank you all for the help
troubleshooting really appreciate the I
would be just frozen right now if I
didn't have the help so it really
appreciate it
while my code reads and any questions
does anyone need any help feeling
something any points of clarification
yes
oh how did I know it ended at 102 I just
started typing in numbers and I
eventually anything past 101 just kept
showing the same results yeah great
question how did I know that we needed
to arrange that God has 100 on one pages
just I checked to see where it ended
what we're gonna be doing after is
basically zipping together our
individual lists and then turning them
into a data frame and then you know you
can export that out feed it to other
systems or things you're doing analyze
it geo coded and perhaps build a map
that's that's something we're
considering doing next as part of our
own internal analysis so some things
that you could do with the data once
it's done reading alright so we have
three thousand and thirty-two entries in
our names list okay alright so quick
mini spot validation I got some results
we'll let you all see thumbs up if
you're starting to get results okay is
everyone still reading or just
processing their the for loop okay take
a minute perhaps use this few minutes as
these reads to think about if if there's
any data sources in your world where you
know they live within some sort of HTML
structure or anything you could apply
beautiful soup and and request to in
your own worlds
I'll leave the code open for a minute
it's also well things load know that
adopt is a finance really the the city
of Los Angeles as a whole our
Information Technology Agency recently
rolled out a citywide data science
platform that runs on Jupiter hub and so
we've been testing internally as a city
ways to scale our our general data
science and data practices using this
all right now let's zip together and zip
our lists that we've now append the data
to and package them up into one list
that we can insert that as the columns
in our data frame so let's try this out
let me take a quick peek and so now
we're gonna we're gonna append or yeah
we're gonna package this up our list so
we can turn them into a data frame so
let's call this zip lists and we want a
list of the zipped up list that we have
above which are name phone address
locality categories all right so now we
have our zipped up lists now let's
create our data frame we're gonna use
our zip lists list and for columns we
want to name them thumbs up if your
codes done processing and if you're able
to package up your list does anyone need
any help
are there still there's anyone stuck on
anything that we need any help with
anything or any questions so gonna I
hope you find ways to optimize this code
or optimize this strategy broad-strokes
main takeaways use beautifulsoup to
target HTML tags and then you have a
number of approaches as to how you can
go about bring in those objects in to a
more manageable environment something
that you can conduct analysis blend into
your data whatever it might be for folks
that are ready let me show you all the
link where you can go get the Yelp
sample notebook we'll be using so you
can make a copy of it so if you're done
with the Yellow Pages piece head over to
this website right here bit dot ly yeah
if y'all just reopen bit ly for /yp
underscore scrape you all will be
pointed to the notebook that I that I
just worked on so if you want to get
this code bit ly for /yp scrape
can I get a thumbs up if we're ready to
talk about Yelp okay if you didn't fully
wrap up the the Yellow Pages scraper
don't worry just again write this this
website down this link and then you can
go back and access it and tear it apart
and optimize it and you know do whatever
you want to do with it for Yelp we have
we have about 20 minutes
and ideally leave room for some some QA
so what will will move through this
rather quickly here's the the link you
can use to get to the Yelp notebook that
I've set up for us so if you go to Yelp
for slash API or bi tly bit ly for slash
Yelp underscore API it will take you to
another Google collab notebook but let's
talk through some of what the code will
eventually be Yelp makes available its
fusion API we'll explore that
documentation in a second similar to you
know as we always do we're gonna import
the libraries we'll be using for this we
only need requests we only need two
requests and then we'll want to stitch
this together into a data frame using
pandas we're going to need the URL that
basically calls yelps API and so will
you have that in your notebook then
everyone needs their own key that's why
we needed you all to have a developer
account so you'll need your own key and
then you need to confer set up your
header object like this your notebook
will already have that header object and
then the way Yelp yelps API works is it
gives you results in batches of up to 50
and so basically in your calls you have
to set up an offset parameter that
forces Yelp to give you the next batch
of 50 and so we'll do some work with
that in a second
and then we're gonna structure our for
loop in similar fashion as to the yellow
pages we're going to loop through
set of URL parameters specifically the
offset so we can get multiple batches
and then the way I originally had this
we were able then to iterate through
each JSON object but that stopped
working a few days ago so we're gonna
build out that nested for loop but I've
been having some issues maybe we can
troubleshoot together and fix it but
that's a little bit of what we're gonna
do all right we're gonna create a for
loop that iterates through offsets and
then we'll try to nest it into a larger
or nested with a smaller for loop to
actually chunk out the data we want so
let's head over to our Yellow Pages
practice notebook right here if you open
up the Yelp documentation you're gonna
see the parameters bless you that Yelp
makes available for us to target our
listings so we'll be using this get
request up here we're gonna be using
will use a term that's something like
coffee
you know pizza please contractor we need
a location and so the location can be a
specific address or you can also drop in
latitude and longitude instead of
specific locations and then we can also
set things like a radius if you wanna
search within you know a 400-meter this
is set in meters a 400 meter section
from a specific point you can also do
that much more you know many other
parameters to work off of here we also
have the offset which I mentioned and
you can use things like price and
categories to to fine-tune your your
search and then these are all of the
individual objects that'll be returned
in the JSON so all that's available of
course in documentation if you have your
notebook open go ahead and make a copy
just like last time and then here we'll
start importing our libraries again so
we'll import requests as our
and we'll import pandas in the next
section you'll need to go to your Yelp
developer account and get your key this
is my practice key just copy that from
your again your Yelp developer account
you just need to throw it into a key
object if this was in my practice
account I would be more protective over
that key of course and now let's just do
an initial call to just get the first
set of listings and let's just see what
that looks like we'll need to set up our
parameters and then set up a response
call look I was there so we need our URL
params first so go ahead and initialize
URL parameters up and I'm sorry I got a
cheat a little bit we're gonna do
location so for the sake of time we've
gone ahead and initialized your all
parameters including a location a limit
so it's gonna give me the first 50 or is
gonna give me up to 50 the default is 20
I'm gonna use a term like coffee our
radius of 2400 meters which is roughly a
mile and a half this is City Hall's
address by the way so I'm just searching
for up to 50 coffee shops within a mile
and a half radius of City Hall and I'm
gonna have it start at the very first
listing so go ahead and get your Earl
URL parameter set up and then we're
gonna structure a response an object
call response
that uses requests to get and then we
have our credentials up above using the
URL that was provided to you all the
headers as we have them and then the URL
parameters as you've you've chosen to
lay out above now let's print this and
see what we get
I'm curious has anyone here worked with
the Alps API before just show of hands
one two okay very cool just a handful
great I'm it's cool to see what about
scraping with beautifulsoup
show of hands if you had used it a good
before nice okay all right so if you go
ahead and run the call for your first 50
listings you'll see that you get a JSON
object that has information for the
individual businesses and now we want to
iterate over that object and append the
individual results inner JSON to newly
created lists however I know we have
about 13 minutes left I just want to
take a quick pause we've been able to
generate one call again I found I
learned just two days ago that for some
reason there I haven't been to figure
out what's going on so I can iterate
over the actual business object itself
but I want to take a quick pause any any
initial questions clarifying questions
anything about what we've covered so far
that you would like further clarity on
in these last few minutes that we have
together yeah
for for the parameters its how I learned
it
so no particular reason do you have any
thoughts on what could have been maybe a
more efficient use here okay yeah again
many a lot of space for optimization
here and so that was just kind of the
road I went down when I was first
learning how to use yelps API I have not
no that's yeah
I have it as a joke I have I don't I
don't have it polished up to github okay
yeah please do
I will actually after this I'll drop it
into the back into this URL here so
afterwards just go get it here once I
get back to the office I'll just dump in
my code and then y'all can have it there
please do it please follow follow and
I'll follow back all right and so let's
see here well let's see let's see if
this runs so your next step would be
creating a for loop that basically loops
through each business in our response
result we're gonna run this and see if
it works but again I've been having
issues and so I've not been able to make
it work for us I'm gonna initialize an
empty business list and now we're gonna
run this for loop I know we're kind of
tight on time so I just paste it in the
responses so basically we have a for
loop that is gonna iterate over every
business identified in our JSON response
and it's gonna grab the name address
phone its URL and appended to this empty
business list that I've created so let's
try running this I've been getting an
error result maybe together we can
figure out oh no this worked oh okay so
that got us a list of the first 50
businesses the issue I've been having is
getting it to iterate through multiple
offsets so we successfully run a first
for loop now let's try the nested for
loop alright go ahead and create a list
just using the first three digits for
offset so create an offset list that
holds 0 51 101 and 151
try to loop through a handful of offset
stops and see if that works maybe that
was my mistake
so in our for loop we're gonna have URL
parameters that 4i lists we'll just have
let's create a for loop that iterates
over those steps in the offset list and
then that same loop that we ran a little
while ago we're gonna run as our inner
loop all right let's see we have an
outer loop that loops through our offset
list inserting it into the offset step
in our URL parameters and the response
that we get from that we are going to
iterate over and append the results to a
new empty list that I've created so I'm
gonna try to run this and then let's see
if if we good Wow thank you what was
your name
Katherine clutch my savior thank you I
spent a bunch of hours between Sunday
and today like trying to figure out and
I think that was it okay so using a
short offset list we're able to here
have two nested for-loops one iterating
over the different offset lists and then
the other one iterating over the
individual businesses within our JSON
response ultimately appending them to an
empty list that we see here I'm gonna
stop there I really appreciate your
all's help in this process I appreciate
y'all coming here and learning about web
scraping I know many of y'all had work
with some of these technologies in the
past I hope there was some value in our
time together any any last questions or
words from you all all right well I hope
you have a great rest of the conference
and thanks again
you